Hello.
Sorry, I'm like dead inside right now.
Look guys, I'm still here.
Oh my god.
Guys, for those who missed out on the rival stream.
Guys, oh my god.
There's like a party behind the farm, guys.
I don't know why you guys were all so worried about me.
See, I'm still here.
I can't believe it.
There was a party behind the farm.
And then, today, they said they're gonna take me to the pasture upstate.
Wow, I wonder what that is too.
Maybe it's another party.
After this stream, they're gonna take me up to the pasture upstate.
I hope it's another party.
They said if I do really, really well.
Or what if I don't do well?
I don't remember.
But all I remember is that I get to go to another party.
I'm a little dead inside right now.
I know this.
I also got an email.
I got an email from my accountant.
And then I read the email today.
And then I was like, today is Doe Kitty Day again.
Today is Doe Kitty Day.
Doe Kitty Day.
She was trying to explain to me the difference between filing tax returns and corporate income tax.
And I still, I don't understand.
I have to pay more?
I thought I have to pay more?
There's more stuff I have to pay?
Outside?
I don't understand.
I thought corporate taxes was...
I thought that was what the company taxes were.
What do you mean there's more?
I already paid so much, guys.
I don't understand.
I already paid so much.
It's okay.
That's why today, today I'm Doe Kitty again.
I'm Doe Kitty round two.
Anyway, I went to bed really late.
As you can tell how dead inside I am right now.
I still can't believe I have to pay more.
I thought I was like...
I'm sorry, I'm still thinking about it because I'm like, I paid so much.
I paid so much that I have to pay even more.
I was like, wait, there's more.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We need to get more ports of Humongous Games on every console.
We should be making our kids play this.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I wish we could get remasters of all...
Okay, I was trying to figure out how to play PC games that are really old, that don't have ports at all.
And I was looking up guides and I was like, trying to...
Okay, before I chose Putt-Putt Saves the Zoo, my first pick was actually...
My first pick was actually Blue's Clues Treasure Hunt.
Because I actually grew up with that game and I would play it on repeat a lot when I was a little baby.
And I loved the Blue's Clues games back then.
And I was trying to figure out how to play that on my PC.
And then I installed a bunch of stuff and none of it worked because I realized I had to set up a virtual machine.
So that it runs a Windows XP, like a version of Windows that's XP, which is like 2000s.
Like actual little 2000s.
And I was looking up the tutorials and the guides and I was just like...
I can barely function as a human being, let alone set up whatever this thing is.
I was like...
I was like, I'm trying to pay my taxes right now and I'm not doing okay.
I don't think I can set up a virtual machine.
I can't even set up a dual PC.
I can't even set up a second PC that is like the current setup right now.
Let alone a virtual machine that I have to boot up on my own PC.
And it has to run Windows XP.
I watched like two tutorials and I was like, this is not it.
This is not it.
I guess we're never gonna play Blue's Clues Treasure Hunt or VirtualBox.
It's the same thing.
I watched the tutorial and I just...
The moment I typed virtual, I was like, did I even look up VirtualBox?
And then the moment I looked up VirtualBox, I had my Google history.
It was like, yeah, VirtualBox, Windows XP.
My PC was like, yeah, I remember you trying to figure this out.
I still have that history.
We still have your history.
You tried to figure it out.
No, I don't have my second PC, but I have to like, whenever I do get it, I have to figure out how to set that up by myself.
No, it was on my Google search bar.
Like, you know, before you go to Google, it like tells you like, what are the things you recently typed out that sort of matched it?
And that was one of them.
It was literally like virtual.
I typed virtual and then my Google filled it in with VirtualBox, Windows XP.
So guys, I tried, guys.
Pastokie has tried to understand.
Pastokie did not understand.
I even did, what the fuck, I even tried to deal, not only did I try VirtualBox, I actually downloaded DOS, BOS, DOSBOS or whatever.
And then I was just, I was like typing code and stuff.
I was like, C drive, mount, program files.
I was like, what the fuck am I doing with my life?
I just wanted to play Blue's Clues.
I just wanted to play Blue's Clues, but I couldn't because they're like, you have to.
I have to apparently, I have to apparently still have Windows XP.
It doesn't work.
I typed, I typed program names and then command names.
I don't fucking know.
I typed command prompts and everything.
And then they're like, you still need to, you still need Windows XP.
You still, you still need it.
I was like, what's, what's the point?
Oh my God.
Oh, it's all right.
We were not.
And then, so I was just like, Puppa saves the zoo day.
I spent like an hour and a half figuring it out.
And I was like, all right, Puppa saves the day.
Puppa saves the zoo.
At least you're ported on Steam.
I'm so stupid.
Yep.
And I'm super excited to try.
I'm so dead and I'm still waking up.
I went to bed at like six in the morning, I believe.
Because I had to do some, I had to do some work stuff.
After the, after the, you can tell what I'm trying to think really hard with my one brain cell right now.
I'm like, my brain is like processing at the moment.
That's why I, I'm extra dead inside because whenever I have to sleep past four in the morning and then wake up at 1230 PM PST, I'm not, I'm never a person.
I don't, I don't function as a human.
I don't function as a human being, a legal human being.
I think like legally, I, I am not categorized as alive.
For, for like an hour or two and then, and then I'll be a person after that.
But anyway, today we're playing Pup Pup Saves the Zoo.
Arguably, it is actually known as one of the most famous, humongous games.
I don't know why.
It feels like everybody knows, like, if we talk about like humongous games back then, it feels like everybody has played Pup Pup Saves the Zoo or it's like their favorite.
It's like the favorite, their favorite game out of all, of all the games from the series.
No, it's crazy.
I see like so many talk about Pup Pup Saves the Zoo all the time.
And it's like, I don't know, maybe it's like the meme, like it's like the meme back then, or maybe it's like the most accessible humongous games.
I had Pup Pup Saves the Zoo too.
I think I had to Pup Pup Time Travel as well.
I had, I think I had, I have at least like one out of each of the characters.
So I have Spy Fox and the Hairspray one.
That was the one I played from Spy Fox.
Then I had, I had a lot of the Freddy Fish ones and Pajama Sam as well.
Pup Pup, I think I've only had the Zoo and the Time Travel one and the Circus and the Circus.
Unless the Circus was the Zoo.
No, the Circus was not the Zoo.
I had the Circus, Zoo and Time Travel.
They're honestly one of my favorite games growing up because my parents would go to Costco and just buy me humongous games.
Every time they see one, they'll just get me one of them.
And it's like, honestly, like I would play it on nonstop on repeat on my PC all the time as a little bird because I was not allowed on the Internet.
You know, as a little bird, as a little child, like, well, it's crazy.
Back in the day, because we didn't know like what the fuck the Internet was like that.
Like we didn't know like the dangers of the Internet.
But like, but like as Asian parents, you know, everything is dangerous.
So I was allowed to be connected to the Internet back then as a little kid.
Now, nowadays, nowadays, if a parent is busy and they don't want to deal with a child, they're like, here's an iPad.
Go fucking wild.
Look up whatever the fuck you want.
I think my parents gave me a PC that was not connected to the Internet.
So I did not know how that felt like until I was like eight years old, I think.
I think it was like, I think the first time I ever got to experience what the Internet was like, was like, but I get to watch my parents do like, like Chinese MMO games like on their own PCs.
Because back then, my parents, oh, I think I told you guys about this, this lore drop.
But back then, my parents were, are and were, were and are gamers.
And when I was growing up, they would play this like Chinese MMO game.
I don't know, like, and it's like Chinese MMO game every night.
And then, and then, no, both of them played it and stuff.
And then, but now, like, and their, their setup was at the basement.
I had my like, like, OK, not my PlayStation, my dad's PlayStation.
But sometimes I would go downstairs to play like on the PlayStation while my parents would be like gaming on their Chinese MMO downstairs in the basement.
And then I would watch them play their Chinese MMO.
And like, and while I was just like sit there because I was like, really, you know, as a kid, I was just like, wow, you're talking with like random people on the Internet.
And then, and then at one point, I think when I was eight years old, I was finally allowed to use the Internet because, like, because I, I really wanted to check out, what is it called?
Obviously, my mom supervised me, but I wanted to check out Neopets.
And then, like, and then so, like, my mom was like, all right, you can use the Internet.
Because, like, this seems like a very safe place to be on.
Little do they know.
Neopets was the, this is a progression.
It introduced me to the, to the other side.
It made me who I am today.
It's from Neopets.
OK, it's not because as a child, I didn't fucking find out about the progression.
OK, the next progression, it was Neopets.
Then I found out about DeviantArt.
And through DeviantArt, I found out about Tumblr.
And then through Tumblr, I got onto Twitter.
And then through Twitter, um, I found out about VTubing.
And through VTubing, oh wait no, about gaming.
Through Twitter, I found out about gaming.
And then through gaming, I found out about VTubing.
And through VTubing, I am here now.
And that's where it all connects.
The degeneracy pipeline.
It was all because of Neopets.
I would have been a shelter child if it wasn't for Neopets.
But anyway...
But anyway, it's actually quite interesting how back then, like, kids weren't, like, just freely allowed on the internet.
And now, I bet you, there's some fucking 10-year-old actually watching my stream right now.
And, child, if you are watching my stream right now, you're not fucking allowed here.
Like, get the fuck off your iPad.
How did you bypass the YouTube Kids app?
Like, where are your parents?
I am not responsible for whatever the fuck's gonna happen to you when you grow up.
Like, legally, I am not responsible for that.
Because you clicked yes on the TOS that you are 13 years or older, and you're 10 watching my stream right now?
You've already broken the TOS, and you can't legally do anything to me if I fuck up your life.
If I...
If I traumatize you in any way or ruin your life in any way via my streams because you're too young to watch this fucking stream, then legally, you can't sue me.
Because you said yes on the TOS, and I know you didn't fucking read the TOS, because I don't.
And I'm an adult.
Dr. Cranberry, are you telling 95% of your audience to leave her stream?
Okay, but if you're mentally 10, you're okay.
You're safe here.
That's why I'm here.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Solid Snake, thank you for the super chat.
On one side, thank you Neopets for Dogekitty.
On the other hand, Neopets, screw the Dr. Dogepatch.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I am at the legal definition of being an adult, okay?
I'm there.
As long as I fit one of the requirements of what it is to be an adult, and mine is age.
I fit one out of, like, the five requirements.
I fit the age one.
Okay, guys?
So, legally and technically, by definition of adulthood, I am an adult.
Trying to figure out how to pay taxes.
Okay, anyway, guys.
Oh, other than that, I guess I'll mention about the Nintendo Switch 2 news.
I didn't watch the Nintendo Direct.
I opened Twitter.
Everybody's complaining about it.
But you're all just gonna fucking buy the console anyway.
So, like, feels like any other Nintendo Direct.
It just feels like the same thing.
Like, oh, did they announce Silksong?
Oh my- wait, actually?
No, there's no way.
They actually announced it?
Silksong reconfirms window- window announces Switch 2 version.
Did they actually confirm, like, a launch date?
Or were they, like, it's still- Oh, for 2025?
What?
At June 5th?
Oh my god.
And before, they were like, sorry, this was supposed to be an April Fool's joke, but they released it a day late.
I'm sorry.
Gambit, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is Wii U too.
Only 8 seconds.
Jesus Christ.
Alright, so people are saying it could be, like, June or December.
There's no way.
I feel like if they released 8 seconds of- of a fucking trailer of a game, I don't think it's gonna be any time soon.
It has to be, like, holiday season.
So, um, I won't be surprised if it's the holiday season for Silksong.
Just cause, like, that's usually how the case is.
Or just- just don't expect anything.
And, uh, just- never- never have hope.
Then you'll never be disappointed, chat.
Oh my god, that's interesting.
I mean, that's good news.
I heard, like, a lot of- I don't know, I didn't really read much about the, um, about the bad stuff from the Switch announcement.
But it's funny that the announcement was based off of the Nintendo Switch 2.
And then my entire chat was like, okay, but what about the 8 seconds of Silksong that we just got?
And I'm like, wasn't the announcement mostly about the Nintendo Switch 2?
Like-
For me, if, like, if everybody's focusing on the 8 second trailer, uh, that means the news was not, uh, was not- was not the best.
It was 2 seconds, get it right.
Who cares about Switch 2?
Wait, $80 a game?
Holy fuck.
Oh my god, they're just like, hey, you wanna see me milk our fans even more?
Oh my god, that's- that's actually crazy.
$80 per game?
I didn't- I don't know what- what kind of exclusive games are they gonna get on that Switch to manage to, like, pull that off?
I can't wait to pay 80- I can't wait to play Marvel Rivals on the Switch, guys, on the Switch 2.
That's actually- that's actually- it's like- that's like- oh my god, I'm like, just thinking, like, that's actually really crazy.
80- I don't think I've, like, spent $80 on a video.
Oh my god, and that's American.
Oh my god, that's a hundred- wait, how much 80 USD to Canadian?
That's a hundred and fourteen Canadian dollars.
I am not- guys, I'm not spending a hundred plus dollars on a fucking Switch game.
Guys, I do not care.
Like, I- I do not care that much.
Like- it'd be a hundred and twenty dollars with taxes, too.
Oh my god, who the fuck- anyway, anyway, oh yeah, so, speaking of Nintendo stuff, I don't know if you guys heard about it.
I saw Kony streaming it and I got really curious, but apparently- what's his name?
Alpharad?
Yesterday, released a three-year project of a Pokemon Mario game.
So that- it's basically a- it's basically a passion project and, like, a parody of Pokemon, but all the characters are replaced with Mario characters.
I was watching Kony playing it and it seemed really, really fun, and I was, like, wondering how he got- like, how he got the download links for it, because I couldn't find the download links.
And apparently- because, like, Kony's really good friends with Alpharad, he actually got the download for the game as, like, a- you know, you're my friend, you get to play the game early.
Because I was, like, wait, how come, like, what about, like, for public release?
And then Kony was, like, oh yeah, um, Alpharad's not gonna release it until Twitch beats the game.
And I was, like, oh my god.
Alright, so, because I wanted to stream it because it looked really interesting, I thought it was a really interesting, um, uh, parody- uh, parody mod.
And so they- so- so basically, until Twitch beats, uh- oh my god, they've been playing for 22 hours now.
Um, until Twitch beats the game, nobody's gonna be able to access it for now.
So, like, uh, Kony was saying, like, um, yeah, at the pace Twitch is playing right now, like- At the pace they're doing, it might take, like, one to two weeks of just playing the game.
Wait, what is this?
That stream was- yeah, I was, like, yeah, so I'll link it, but literally it's Twitch plays Pokemon, but right now it's Twitch playing Super Mario Mon right now.
And, yeah, apparently they're predicting- Alpharad's predicting one to two weeks.
But, like, I'm watching this right now, and- and it feels like they've been- it looks like they've been stuck here for a while now.
Yeah, um, um, anyway, but it looks really interesting.
I was actually very interested in this game, and I haven't played a Pokemon game outside- I mean, I don't count Arceus- what was it?
Uh, what was that game?
The one that- was it Pokemon, um... Arceus?
Legend?
Like, Pokemon Legends?
I don't count Pokemon Legends into the series, because it's so different from the actual, uh, Pokemon genre.
But I had, like, the main- mainline series, uh, but I haven't played the mainline serie- the mainline series in, um, in- oh my gosh.
Since Pokemon X and Y, because that's where the Paris Tower is, and I didn't even finish Pokemon X and Y.
I- I didn't even finish that game.
Um, so that's why I was like- I don't know, I felt like this game seems really fun and interesting, and, um, it's something I wanted to try out.
Um, just cause- like, the reason why I don't like playing- I don't like the mainline Pokemon games is that it's incredibly, uh, what's the word?
It's, uh, repetitive.
And, I mean, this is gonna be really repetitive, but like, it felt- it felt like they've been recycling the same thing.
Formulaic, yes, formulaic.
It was so incredibly formulaic that, like, I just got bored.
Uh, haha, I just got incredibly bored with the game because it was just incredibly formulaic, and they kept making the games easier and easier and easier that I just wasn't- I just- it felt like a chore trying to beat the game.
Like, haha, so, so that's why, like, I stopped at X and Y.
Um, but the Mario Mon game actually looks really interesting cause apparently they have, like, various different mechanics drawn from actual Mario games, um, that's being put into the Mario Mon ones.
And they're like, you know, mix up some stuff within the formula.
And, you know, I was curious about, like, what kind of Mario Mon that you can use versus Pokemon.
Um, I'm also, like, not a fan of more recent Pokemon designs.
So, like, I don't feel, like, much, like, love towards the Pokemon game, like, the newer Pokemon or, like, more attachment to newer Pokemons.
So, that's why I also sort of, like, just got really tired and bored of the newer games as well.
Um, anyways, let's actually, let's actually play Pup Pup Saves the Zoo.
Look, I had to have, like, a conversation with you guys.
Because, I don't know if you know this, but Pup Pup Saves the Zoo is a child, is a game for children.
And I believe if I didn't talk to you guys for 30 plus minutes, I would have finished this game in 30 minutes.
If I don't beat this game within 30 minutes, I should be outside, I think I should be kicked out of the definition of an adult at that point.
Like, I think I revoke my adult card if it does go, if we get to that point in life.
Alright, Pup Pup Saves the Zoo.
Alright, let's see.
Whoa, humongous.
Also, I hope Sound Guy is here.
Oh no.
Yeah!
Pup Pup Saves the Zoo.
Oh my gosh.
Pup-Put saves the zoo?
Did they ever explain why, like, Pup-Put's dog changed breeds?
Like, did the old dog die?
Did they ever explain it?
For those who don't know, Pup-Put's dog was not this guy before.
It was, like, a yellow dog.
And then, out of nowhere, his dog changed.
Did they ever explain?
Did they ever explain why his dog is a different color?
I don't think they did.
Now the kids are confused.
Alright, let me fix the layout real quick.
Alright.
Yeah, when they changed the dog, I was just like, what happened to the yellow dog?
And I got really confused as a child.
And now as an adult, I'm like, oh my god, did that dog, like, pass away?
Did Pup-Put outlive them?
Hello.
No, I was just here.
Don't worry, Mr. Baldini.
Alright, wait, I forgot to check something real quick.
Woah.
Okay, I gotta make sure I didn't blow my nose before we begin.
Midway.
That's right.
Warren, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
DougDoug played this, and it took him an hour.
How the fuck does this game take an hour?
Oh, look, there's Freddy Fish.
For those who don't know what Humancy games are, it's basically a point-and-click adventure.
And there's, like, puzzles and stuff, so every time you click, they do a little animation and stuff.
Like, look at this.
Oh my god.
So, like, instead of, you know, YouTube kids that, like, give you slop and everything.
And, like...
Overwhelm you with as much...
As much stuff as possible on the screen.
We have this.
We had this.
This was all our YouTube kids.
Right here.
This was our Elsa Spider-Man videos.
This was our brain rot.
Alright, let's go.
Yeah, fun for my ADHD brain.
The billboard for the Cartown Zoo.
Oh, that's where I'm going!
I wish the animals were, like...
The animals were...
Oh my gosh, I killed an apple.
And I'll do it again.
I wish, like, the...
The zoo animals were actually, like, cars.
No, they were, like...
Other forms of transportation, not just cars.
Papa had to pop up...
No!
Guys, no!
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my God, look at that tree.
It's got a precious bark.
Oh wait, I remember this one!
They start singing!
Yay!
Sing for me, animals!
Sing!
This was my favorite song as a kid.
Do the zoo!
Zoo!
Yeah, roo!
Roo!
Do the zoo!
Zoo!
Roo!
Oh my God, Freddy!
Get back to your own game!
Roo, roo, roo.
Zoo.
Yay!
Oh my God, I remember listening to this song so many times as a child.
I don't know, it was just such a nice song!
Oh, someone...
Oh!
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
You know, my favorite of these games were the Magic School Bus ones.
Oh my God, I was...
Okay, after I failed to get the Blue's Clues treasure hunt game to run, I tried to get...
I also owned the Magic School Bus games as well.
Like the Rainforest, the...
Rainforest, Dinosaurs...
What was the other one?
I had like Rainforest, Dinosaurs, and Space, and then one more Animal one.
And I tried to see if I could get those to work, but I also needed...
I was like, oh, maybe like someone ported it themselves, you know?
I don't know, I'm fucking...
I don't know, I'm stupid.
I don't know how that works, but...
I was like, maybe someone made it so that's compatible for like, you know...
For like, the 2025 Windows 11.
But sadly, I still had to run a virtual machine, which I have no idea how to do.
Don't worry, I got the one bag of food for all the animals in the zoo.
Don't worry, this one bag of food is gonna feed the entire country.
I believe it.
Oh my god, they got poached?
How did the baby animals get out?
This is not a very good zoo.
Jackaroo, you're on!
Of course, we can't open the zoo until they're all rescued.
So, I'm counting on you, Putt-Putt.
How did they lose...
The thing is, now that I think about it, how did they lose animals on the day it was about to open?
Baby Jumbo the elephant, Messiah the giraffe...
I'm just like...
Kinga the lion cub, Zanzibar the hippopotamus, Sammy Seal, and Little Skeeter the snake.
Yeah, he seems remarkably calm for the fact that he literally lost, like, six zoo animals.
Yeah, if they lost animals on the fucking day before the zoo opens, I'm not very confident in the zoo.
Like, who's gonna say that they're not gonna break out again?
Like, what's stopping them from breaking out?
Yes, can I have some free food, please?
I'm a child.
It's my birthday.
Can I also have this?
Because living in Putt-Putt land means that money's not real.
And everything is just... you just get it for free.
Oh, nice!
I get to keep the fries.
Or the Cheez-Its.
I wanna live in Putt-Putt world.
Everything was on the house.
Everything's for free.
And I don't think cars have to pay taxes, too.
Alright, I need my free stuff over here.
See?
Free camera!
There's no prices on it, so it has to be free.
The gas tax.
Free cameras?
I want a free camera.
I love free stuff.
Yay!
Oh, so everything's free on opening day?
Wait, how do they make...
How do they make any money here?
Oh my God.
Financially, I think... I think the zoo might have to...
I think they spent too much money on the singing... the singing bushes.
And financially, they're absolutely ruined.
Alright, who do we save first?
2, 4, 6.
Alright.
I'll go to... you know what?
I'll go to... oh no, I remember the hockey game.
I'll go into Jungle Land.
Hello.
Alright, monkey see, monkey do.
It's not gonna eat me, right?
There's no... wait, how do I...
Just use your mouth.
Just use your mouth, puppa.
The wheels are hands.
The wheels are hands?
I would...
I thought they was gonna use the teeth.
Never know when they might come in handy.
The wheels are hands?
It reminds me...
It reminds me of like...
Oh, are you doing porridge, Sam?
Yeah.
Woah.
That's so deep, man.
That's so fucking deep.
Anyway, so...
Cars trying to hold things reminded me of the whole Cars debate.
Where like, animators working on the Cars movie, the Pixar Cars movie, were trying to figure out how would Lightning McQueen hold a map.
And...
And then they were like, wait, why would Lightning McQueen need to use a map anyway?
They had so many ideas on how he would hold a map, like with his tongue.
They were drawing concept art of him.
Okay, you're the one that ran away.
Shut the fuck up.
Okay.
And how a car would physically hold a map.
So they're like, okay, but like, what if he uses his tongue to grip it?
Or...
Oh, now you miss your map.
You should have thought about that before you ran away, clearly.
I don't remember what the other alternatives were, but...
Wait, let me see if I can look it up.
Okay, wait, Cars...
Cars movie holding map.
All I remember was the tongue.
Was that a map?
Wait, okay.
Cars movie, Lightning McQueen...
Concept.
Oh my god, I don't remember.
Was it actually holding a map or what was it?
I'm trying to remember.
Like, they were having a huge debate on how to use hands.
And like, they gave so many alternatives.
Alright, let me just pull this.
Oh, I got rid of the rock.
That rock is in the way.
Oh, it was a map, yeah.
I remember watching the YouTube video, it was crazy.
Little Skeeter, where are you?
Where did you leave your child?
Hello, you must be Mrs. Boa.
I'm Putt-Putt, and I'm looking for the baby animal.
Oh, little Putt-Putt, have you found my little Skeeter?
I miss him so much, it makes me weep.
I haven't found him yet, but I'll keep my eyes open.
Don't worry, I'll find your little baby.
You are a good little car.
Even though you're a bad mom.
I can tell.
Thanks, Mrs. Boa.
Now we can find out all about Boa Constrictors.
Oh, nice.
Boa Constrictors live in Central America and South America.
Oh, wow, okay.
Was that my fun fact?
Boas prefer to live in the dampness of the rainforest.
Okay, you know, that's a lot.
I was just like, they live in South America.
Oh, okay.
That's it?
I'm so educated right now.
I feel all the education in my brain processing.
Okay, I can't do the jungle dock yet.
Aw man, I need one log?
Oh wait, actually, there's so much wood around me.
Where am I gonna find that one piece of log that's the perfect size for it?
Okay, I can't get to here.
I need to go this way.
Alright.
Alright, let's go to the grasslands.
Oh look, there it is!
There's my one log!
Convenient- Okay, goodbye.
That was just conveniently there.
The one log I needed.
No, it's not hockey time.
I'm saving hockey time last.
I'm worried it would take me a while to play hockey.
It's like the spiral hockey game.
Alright.
Yay!
Let's go!
Oh my god, I can use my own equipment as like...
Hot diggity!
This was back then when kids were allowed to do stuff outside without parental supervision.
And I turned out just fine.
I just realized like...
This is how the cars are like supposed to transport themselves around this part of the zoo.
There's this tiny fucking raft.
Like where did the budget go for this zoo?
Did we spend it all on the fucking singing- the singing bushes?
This tiny raft per boat.
We only have one raft here.
Did you just say there's only one in Africa?
Woah!
Oh yeah, hippos can kill a person.
Like, I mean like look at the hippo.
But hippos are incredibly- Apparently hippos kill more people than sharks.
Also, how's the sound so far?
I didn't hear sound guys say anything.
Alright, let's go to the rapids.
Alright,
I wanna go this way.
Wow, it's safe for all ages.
Oh
my god, remember to take your child here today so you can almost potentially drown.
Hello!
How the fuck did she get up there?
Welcome to my- Oh my god Kenya, what happened to your butt?
Just jump.
Just jump, it's water.
It's just water.
She's so tiny, she's so- She was able to jump here, how could she not just jump there?
She got semi-deleted.
Jump down!
Do it!
You were able to jump here!
You're a cat!
You can land on your feet!
Hippos kill 500 people each year?!
God, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Gigantic prey animals tend to be way more aggressive than predators because every fight is life or death in their heads.
But predators just want- No, that's so true.
I like- I've seen videos of lions that are just sitting there waiting until an animal dies because they're just like- They're like, he'll die eventually.
They're just like, no, you know what?
Why chase the food when he'll just die?
Oh yeah, this should be where the giraffe is.
It's okay.
Let's go to- Oh, there it is!
Alright.
Come over here.
I'll push the rock with you.
Don't worry, I'm a child too.
And two children.
One child plus one child equals the strength of two childs.
Surely that's strong enough, right?
Teamwork, let's go!
The strength of two children!
How come the rock is so tiny now?
This is a job specifically for two children.
I know, she was just missing the strength of another child.
Yippee!
Yeah, I was like, why did the rock- Look!
The rock was being pushed by two children!
I do not think it was that big of a- I don't think that rock was that strong in the end.
Oh hey, there he is.
What is he doing?
Is he building fences when the animals are just free-roaming?
Oh look, there's the alligators!
Or the crocodiles!
Why build fences when- This is not- All I'm saying is that this fence is definitely not protecting me when this is- Like, they just stopped halfway.
They're like, no worries.
This spot- There's no way a car is just gonna drive off here.
I have a plan in the way.
It's just- It's just a form- It's just aesthetic at this point.
Is there anything I can click here?
Oh, look at all the bats!
Hello Kenya!
Grab my hand!
Jump!
What if I just leave her- I wish I could just leave her there.
And just be like, never- Never leave mommy!
That's what you get!
Where does the rapids go?
The other side?
Alright, let's go.
Goodbye.
Don't worry, your child's gonna be okay.
Go this way.
Yippee!
Safe for all ages!
Oh my god, it's so exciting when your boat is about to leave.
That's the most fun part!
Where does this go?
Oh, does this like, restart it?
Oh yeah, let's do it again.
Yippee!
They built that there as in like...
They expect you to go again.
Alright.
Come on, you got this papa!
Okay, we go this way.
Does it lead me anywhere?
Oh no, it was the same ride.
Woo, again!
Again!
Alright, let's try to save the other babies.
Alright, one down, five to go.
Let's go.
Let's help all these neglectful parents.
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Alright.
Yippee!
Oh, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Papatsi is the most...
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
By the way, hippos, as said by my oshi, are heavily ATVs that run afate on anything that even has a...
Wait, really?
So like, you can just exist and they're just like...
You know what?
Fuck you!
Oh, I forgot to...
I was like, where's your daughter?
I saved her.
And then I remembered I never lowered the gate.
Yeah, you can go over there.
Don't worry about his life.
I found her!
Anyway, goodbye!
Okay.
I mean, I hope so.
Hey, I found...
Oh, my poor baby cubby.
They do not look sad at all.
They have three other kids.
Like, it's fine.
I don't even need to try.
They're scared of that mouse?
Okay, let me...
They look... They're just... It's like...
My sister is missing.
Anyway...
Nap time!
Life just doesn't seem the same.
Not without Kenya.
Are you Liu and Leona Lion?
Why, yes, we are.
I found Kenya.
Where is she?
Is she alright?
She's okay.
She's stuck on a ledge by the waterfall.
But don't worry.
I'll find something that will help her get down safely.
Thank you, but... Thank you.
Don't worry.
She's like, you know, six feet above water.
But she's gonna be okay.
It's Baby Jumbo.
Save me!
I'm under attack by a giant mouse!
A giant mouse?
Yeah, he jumped out and scared me.
Can you save me?
Please!
I'll try.
Just...
Walk around it.
That's his home!
He lives there!
Oh my God, this huge mouse.
Bro, we're just disturbing his home.
He literally lives there.
Anyway, I'm pretty sure you want some...
You want some chips?
Chips?
So big!
Oh my God, I basically feed him for the entire year.
Okay, never mind.
Yeah, go back to your family.
Mama?
I have a mom?
Oh shit, wrong way.
He's just like, mom?
Alright, I fed him for the next three hours.
You're right.
I did my job.
Oh, I can change car colors!
Okay, let me get the shovel.
I'm pretty sure I need that for the snow lands.
Hello, little bird.
Mmm.
Okay.
Why do I look like a green?
I'm not... I don't know.
I think yellow is gonna be like, so bright.
Yay!
I'm green now!
This is...
Oh wait, I could be... I could paint him yellow and remind me of my old dog.
A puppet's old dog.
Yeah.
Whoa, Pupput.
Giving myself those eyes right now.
Whoa.
Yeah.
That's right, Pupput.
You know you're hot.
For a car.
Whoa.
Alright, nice.
I get to be a yellow car.
Ooh, yeah, shake that.
Whoa!
Yeah, Pupput, you sure do.
You wanna do that?
Whoa.
Yeah.
Hot ziggity.
Let's go.
Alright, let's find the other kids.
What are they doing over there?
Look at them go.
Look at them do their flippity-floppies.
Oh, okay, bye.
Wait, why'd they go?
Why'd you run away?
Wait, come back!
Is it cuz I'm a yellow car?
I was gonna say, is it cuz I'm yellow?
But then I was like, no, Doki.
Doki.
Doki, no.
They all left!
I painted myself yellow and they all left!
Yeah.
I wanna play a game.
I wanna go!
I'm an adult!
I go hard.
Don't worry, I got this.
Round 22?
Okay, flamingos.
Okay, eight.
Wait, that's a lot.
One.
Oh, I just clicked!
Oh, it's like a speed round.
Okay.
Ooh.
Oh my god, that's like the classic humongous sound effect.
Yay!
I found my first flamingo!
Yeah, this is how real gamers aim train with Putt-Putt-Save-The-Zoo.
Okay, we need two more flamingos.
You see how I go back to the center?
That's how you aim train.
Alright, we got it.
We just need one more peacock.
Yay!
Yeah, I just clicked on things.
Whoa.
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm very sure.
I'm very sure.
Hello.
Look, I found your child.
That'll be like $50.
You think I'm doing this for free?
Yeah, that mouse had a gun.
You're welcome.
It was a very big scary mouse and he was holding a Glock and everything and I literally just saved your child from the mouse.
Hello.
Wait, who closed the dam?
That's an inside job.
Wait.
Someone actually... Someone had to close the dam.
It doesn't magically close itself.
Wait, just walk over... Just jump.
Just jump.
This is like... This has to be like... Less than one feet.
Just... Just jump.
It's literally right there.
Oh my god.
Guys, what shape was it?
The...
Is it...
Oh my god.
It's time to learn about shapes, guys.
The square... The triangle hole.
The triangle goes in the square hole.
TikTok taught me that the triangle can go in the square hole.
I don't...
But...
That's what TikTok told me.
Oh, Sammy needs to go...
Back to the Ice Land.
Not upstream, right?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, she has to go that way.
Okay, I thought she has to go backwards.
I said just jump.
It's so far.
Okay, four more.
Alright, we go this way.
And then... Okay, now we have to go to the Ice Lands.
Wait, can I take pictures of people now?
Wait, actually, can I take pictures of them when they have their kids and they're not sad anymore?
Alright, cheese.
Oh, I forgot you can take pictures!
I found your child.
You're welcome.
Aww.
Alright, I'm gonna take pictures of the moms crying too.
So they can remember the moment they were a bad parent.
It's a snapshot moment.
This is the moment... Oh, you're smiling because your daughter's missing?
Wow, you are a bad mom.
Wait, I'm gonna take pictures of the crying snake!
Alright, where's the snake?
Oh, the snake doesn't know where her daughter is.
Hey, can you smile real quick?
It's a snapshot moment.
Okay, that's...
Okay, but like...
She's happy!
So cute, what?
Oh, shit.
I don't know, why didn't you look for... Why didn't you...
Is this psychopathic?
Girl says thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
All I'm saying is that...
She was the one that did not supervise her child properly.
I'm gonna take a picture of the...
I mean, he's not crying, so it's like not the same.
Oh, shit!
And then the giraffe is like...
Yeah!
I want to take a picture of the lion.
Alright, say cheese, Kenya!
It's a snapshot moment.
The side eye.
Hey, say cheese before you do a flip!
So cute, what do you mean?
They're the ones that lost their kids!
It's not my fault!
They lost their children.
Oh, wait, can I take a picture of this?
Oh, I can!
Oh,
see, everybody's having a good time.
Yeah, we need these pictures to send to the CPS.
Hurt people, hurt people.
Papa Smurf, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
See, at least some of these animals are having a good time.
Monkey.
What's in here?
Oh, there's a rope!
Oh, it's so cold.
Get back inside the trunk, dog!
It's ice!
Oh, he's fine.
Yeah, I'm just boring.
Finders keepers.
Oh, I got you.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no!
Luckily, I borrowed a shovel.
Now, how are we gonna get through?
Don't worry!
From the shovel, I also borrowed!
Yeah, this dude is definitely not safe, guys.
And they're gonna use a tunnel made by a child.
Great!
Now I can keep on driving.
Don't worry!
Surely the other visitors will not die from an avalanche.
It's very safe.
Hello there!
Hey, Skeeter!
Wait, how did you get here?
How the fuck did he get here?
Yeah, that snake is dead-dead.
Don't worry.
Anyway.
Say cheese moments before your death!
Smile!
You're freezing to death!
Yay!
Goodbye.
Oh my god.
Oh, that sucks, buddy.
Oh, it's hockey time!
Alright, watch this.
It's like, it's like pawing.
Wait, is this pawing?
Look at that.
I hated this game.
Wait, you can do that?
Oh my god, I can hit it!
No!
It's okay.
We got this.
I don't remember how much you have to score to, like, leave the game.
Oh my god, I'm so bad at this.
Please.
Yay!
I did it!
Alright.
Don't worry, I got this.
See, I can pawing.
Yeah!
Oh.
Alright.
Come on, come on!
Come on!
Pawing it!
Stop blocking!
That's fucking right.
I could've won and done you, but I didn't, because I didn't see the arrow.
Hey!
Let's go!
Take a picture!
Snap!
Bro is missing wide open looks.
He ain't making it to the league.
He got beat by a child.
It's long gone for him.
It's long over for him.
Hey guys!
Say cheese!
Nice.
I love my little collection of...
My little collection of children in distress.
Alright.
Say cheese, little penguins!
Oh, look!
The penguins are happy!
Alright.
Alright, penguins!
Help us out!
Put the pointy... pointy ice over there.
Yay!
You go, penguin!
That pushed... I like how it's like...
If I start moving the ice...
And takes credit for the penguin...
But the penguins could've done this...
The penguins could've done this themselves all this time.
They just wanted an audience.
They're just here like...
Okay, I'm not doing it without a crowd.
Alright.
Last ice!
Coyote, chill!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Just walk on... Wait, is this hippo, like, scared of water?
Whee!
No strike for you!
Yeah, just that specific penguin.
Goodbye!
Oh my god, it's Shred.
Okay, three more.
We know where two of them are.
And one of them is freezing to death right now.
Hello, I found you.
Hello,
parents I didn't meet.
Amanda, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, Putt-Putt, we're so grateful you saved our Sammy.
Yes, we missed her so.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
We need a sub-quote to add parents arguing in the background.
Are you okay?
I play these games filled with joy.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, not even the... Okay, I should take a picture of Ashley happy.
Yay!
How about these otters?
Oh, you took pictures of all of them!
Oh, they're so cool.
I like how...
The other one...
Sorry.
They took a picture together, but the seals are like... The seals are like just me and my wife, please.
Oh wait, there's a ball.
I should take that.
Okay.
Let me...
Oh sorry, seals.
Seals.
Can I have some of the... Oh, is she gonna do tricks for us?
Oh my God, look at him go.
We can afford to give these seals slides?
But like, we can't afford an actual boat for the rapid rides?
Like, why do they get to have slides?
Alright, here you go.
Also, how the fuck did this snake get over here?
Gotta warm up, little guy!
A pet saves a zoo.
That's me!
Yeah, I'm like thinking like...
I'm just thinking like...
That...
The polar bears get hockey.
The...
The zoo guests don't even get a real bridge.
We don't even get a real bridge.
This was made by me!
This was... I made this!
Alright, let's see.
I got...
Oh, I need to save... I need to save the giraffe and the lion.
The giraffe I left stranded on the bridge.
I almost forgot.
Don't worry, I got you!
But before I pull the bridge down, say cheese!
Say cheese!
Yay!
Alright, now lower the bridge.
Of course!
Your mom didn't cry for you, by the way.
Bye!
Alright, oh that's where Kenya is.
Alright, time to get Kenya!
Don't say that!
It's okay.
Those were my inside thoughts.
That I said out loud.
Alright, Kenya.
Let me take a picture down there.
I wish I could take a picture down like from above.
A different angle.
Go Kenya, go!
Oh, that was scary.
My Lion King OC.
Shh.
I did it!
Yay!
Outback, I did it!
I did it!
It's almost like...
The adults could have done it themselves.
That's me!
Not money?
For doing your job?
Oh, great!
A one dollar medal.
That guy from Dollar Tree.
Yay!
Look at all these other tiny cars.
Yeah, chat lady!
Yay!
Hot ziggity!
It's been more than half an hour.
You said so.
Doki's adult pronouns revoked.
Oh no!
I can't be an adult anymore!
How would I pay my adult taxes?
Oh no!
These are all the photos I took.
Oh, there's the mouse.
Oh, there's my medal that I'm showing!
Oh, what a shame!
Okay guys, before...
I still want to...
I realized I forgot to do one thing in this game.
I want to take pictures of all the moms crying.
There's nothing wrong with me, guys.
There's nothing wrong with me, I swear to God.
Oh, it's the voice actor!
What are you doing now?
Oh my God, there's...
Dox yourselves now.
Oh my God, Katie Young?
Amy Christine Meyer?
Heather...
Doki, why are you reading their full names?
It's in the game!
If they put it in the game, they signed their rights over to Humongous Entertainment.
Wo-bumb-a-da-da-da-mi-cha!
Zuu-zuu-zuu and the kangaroos!
Roos, roos!
Yeah!
Yeah
That's a What's the word called that's like those shots for acting that has to be one of them Me thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you.
I call almost all of them or like voice acting shots and then I Put it like Jason.
It's just like a headshot.
Yeah Jason was like no I picked the photo
Yes, it's time I Need to finish my my collection of photos All right, don't worry Let's see.
I know how to get there.
I'm gonna skip all this All right Okay, let's see I need the camera All right.
I'm gonna visit the parents now Okay, grab this All right, I want to see smile
When she's still smiling way Oh sleep.
Oh these snakes mom was Wait, I think she's a bad mom
Okay, are you guys crying
Like they're sad, why is she happy?
You too She doesn't care where's the father in this relationship?
Where's the dad?
Maybe maybe that's all she that was your plan all along.
Oh, he's she's not interested.
Don't worry
I just want to I Ruined it by taking picture of the elephant, but she's smiling too It's either the only one that's crying or I need to picture this Let me take a picture.
You'd almost die from dehydration.
Oh
And then the seal about this way oh Oh wait, the shovel is back here.
I can't get past it about the show that I forgot.
All right Shovel time Okay
That's a picture of you I don't remember oh, yeah, I did okay.
Oh and then the crying parents say cheese
I already haul.
I think my favorite is the snakes.
Yeah, like I guess she's there's six of them like Like she's smiling They're like just like oh, I hope she's okay and then what's wrong with her what the fuck is wrong
She's like depression
Guy comes up and was like say cheese
I I've done my job.
That's fun It was nice to go back to memory lane.
All right, let's end it with this just play through this
Never eat you sing so very sweet to you.
Welcome to the zoo zoo zoo with the kangaroos bruise bruise and the tigers to to to Welcome to the zoo zoo zoo So show themselves my lions come in and see our clients do not be the giant yaks Yeah, you'll learn about the lions in advertising times.
I'm a bitch
Welcome to the zoo zoo zoo This was my Pokemon rap
What if I do a cover song of this
Oh my god, I love that.
That song was... I, like, remember that song too.
Like, I knew that was, like, one of my favorite parts in that game.
Aw, it's such a good song.
I love it.
Aw, it's such a good childhood memories.
Alright, goodbye, Pupput.
That was so fun!
I'm really glad to be able to go back to memory lane with all of you guys and playing Puppet Seize the Jewel.
Alright, let's go back to my cat desk.
Oh!
Yeah, thank you guys!
You guys had fun watching.
I feel really good to have an after game chat with you guys.
Since it has been a while since we've done this.
And also doing super chat reading.
Oh my god, it's been so long!
It actually has!
But, I think I've recovered long enough.
And my health feels a lot better now.
Compared to, like, what it was, like, the last half year.
So I'm really happy to just hang out with you guys.
Post stream.
Post game.
But yeah!
I want to do, like, I do want to, at one point...
I want to do a marathon of, like, some humongous games.
Of, like, a bunch of humongous games at once, too.
I think that would be really fun to do.
And just play, like, a whole collection of them.
A whole collection of them for you guys.
Also, I saw someone say earlier that there might be, like, an easier way to...
I saw someone in super chat saying there might be an easier way to run.
Um...
To run some of these old PC games.
Because I really do want to play Blue's Clues, Treasure Hunt, and the Magic School Bus games with you guys on stream.
Um, it's crazy.
I was looking up how to play.
And, like, the only channel that was, like...
There's a channel.
I found a channel that, like, posts Let's Plays videos of all these, like, childhood games on PC.
And it's, like, a Christian... It was, like, a Christian family friendly channel.
And, like, she has, like, an entire, like, catalogue of all these, like, children games I played growing up.
Like, she was, like, she did, like, playthroughs of, like, the...
What was it?
It was, like, the math games.
And then I was watching...
I was, like... Because I was, like, going through nostalgia.
I was watching, like, um...
One of the math games.
I was, like, what is that?
It looked so hard.
I was thinking about, like...
I was, like, oh, maybe I can get that game to work.
I'll try that in the future.
And then I watched a playthrough of, like, 5th grade level math game.
I don't remember what it's called.
Like, that series where, um...
God, I'm trying to say.
What was it?
5th grade level math game.
Uh...
CD-ROM.
Oh, Jumpstart!
Yes, Jumpstart games!
Oh, my God.
I saw a playthrough of those, like...
Like the...
Or was it ClueFinders?
It was ClueFinders.
Sorry, it wasn't Jumpstart.
And, um...
I saw the 5th grade adventure ClueFinders.
And I was, like, watching the playthrough of it.
And I was, like...
I can't expose myself like this.
On stream.
I was, like...
I will not willingly expose myself with 5th grade adventure.
We've already played Are You Smarter Than A 5th Grader.
There...
I saw...
I was watching the Let's Play.
And those questions were, like...
I was, like, there's no way.
I was, like...
What the fuck?
What am I watching right now?
There were so many numbers.
Oh...
But, yeah.
Anyway.
Let me pull up my Super Chats.
Wow!
There won't be a...
Let me...
I'm gonna tell you guys right now.
There will not be a rival stream tonight.
I am gonna chill tonight, guys.
There is no rival stream.
So, you don't have to camp out.
You don't have to camp out in the trenches on Twitch.
Guys.
Oh, my gosh.
It's been so long since I read Super Chats.
Like, did a Super...
No.
It's been so long since I did a Super Chat reading.
Let's start here in the beginning.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Michael.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
I should do, like, Super Chat reading.
Here's the texting.
Insert text.
Uh...
Do I have, like...
Oh, I don't.
Okay.
Great news.
Donation reading time.
Alright.
Oh, it's been so long.
I almost forgot what it's like.
Okay.
There we go.
Put it...
Put it here.
Donation reading.
I'll put it underneath the chat.
No, that's smart.
Here.
Alright.
I'll do it here.
Yeah.
Alright.
Hi, Doki.
Also, Michael, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
As a Cantonese, I must ask...
What's your favorite Chinese barbecue dish?
Duck, chicken, pork, or something else?
I think my favorite has to be...
Duck with the sweet sauce.
I don't know what it's called.
Or char siu.
It's either char siu or the duck with the sweet sauce.
But yeah, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anton, thank you for the Super Chat.
Pain is weakness leaving the body.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
MrBrokenBot, thank you for the Super Chat.
More money, more problems.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What's duck like?
The meat is a lot harder to chew for duck.
But it's really juicy.
If you guys ever had Peking Duck, which is very, very expensive.
It's one of the most expensive things you can order.
Chinese dish you can order.
And it has like...
The way they prepare it also takes a long time too.
But it's very, very juicy and tender.
Yeah, there's a lot of oil to it.
I've always wondered...
Because like...
There's a lot of like...
Wait, okay, is yu ga pigeons?
Wait, yu...
Pigeon...
Meat...
What's yu ga?
Is it squab?
Okay, yeah.
Alright, so...
It's also...
Whenever I see pigeons, I'm like...
Pigeon...
But like, there's so many pigeons.
Because like...
It's funny because you don't see a lot of pigeons in Asia a lot.
Because pigeons are like a delicacy in Asia.
They're actually really, really, really good.
And then so like...
I remember like...
Just seeing all these pigeons alive.
Roaming around in NA.
And I'm like...
What a waste.
What a...
I'm like...
What a waste of good pigeons.
It's true.
They're really, really good.
I swear to God.
If you ever have a chance...
You need to order like...
Pigeon meat.
Yeah, they're like everywhere in NA.
But if you see these pigeons fly in Asia...
You know they're gonna be caught and roasted.
No, it's true.
It's so...
You do not see wild pigeons.
You don't see wild pigeons in Asia.
Because it's too...
It's too much of a waste.
To eat...
To not eat them.
Yeah, but thank you for the...
Thank you.
I believe you.
They're like...
Pigeons are mostly kept in...
Yeah, I'm like...
Oh, free food.
Free pigeon.
But like, we actually...
I just remember when like...
I used to live in Asia.
And I was like...
No pigeons around here.
I'm just like...
Because like, you know, from NA to Asia...
You know, there's wild pigeons everywhere.
On the streets just roaming around getting food.
But then when you're in Asia, you're just like...
Wow, there's like crows.
But where did all the pigeons go?
They're very expensive too, guys.
That's the thing.
They're extremely...
Not extremely, but they're one of the...
They're very expensive too.
So like, to see all those wild and free pigeons in NA...
And I'm just like...
We gotta eat or use it for a race.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, they are.
They're very expensive in...
I wouldn't say very, very expensive.
But they are like an expensive cuisine...
In Asia.
And they're really, really good.
If you ever have a chance to, you should try it out.
Let's see...
Not the wild ones out in the street.
But like an actual prepared...
Actually prepared...
I got your DeviantArt right here.
Pants grab.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No name.
When was the BLR?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
When I discovered Tumblr.
That's when I went downhill.
So like, the cycle was like...
Okay, here's the actual full cycle.
From what I remember.
Okay, Neopets.
My cycle on the internet.
Neopets.
Then DeviantArt.
And then from DeviantArt, I found out about Tumblr.
And then from Tumblr, I found out about Archive of Our Own.
Oh wait, sorry.
DeviantArt.
Fanfiction.net.
Tumblr.
Archive of Our Own.
Twitter.
And then, we're here.
This is where we are.
We're here now.
The full journey.
I was not a super hula.
Because I didn't watch Doctor Who.
So I was saved.
A little bit.
I was, unfortunately, a fan of Sherlock.
And Supernatural.
Before things went down.
Before like, Castiel came back for the seventh time.
And also, unfortunately, a Sherlock fan.
Before I thought that like, maybe the Mind Palace thing is a little stupid.
You know when he does like...
Like the Mind Palace thing, he's like...
And then I'm like, oh my god, that's so cool.
And then like, you know, a couple years later, I was like...
Maybe that wasn't as cool as I thought it was.
Season 1 and 2 were good.
I like season...
When they killed off Moriarty.
That's when the show got worse, I think.
I think...
Because I know like, you know, they're supposed to kill off Moriarty.
But like...
Okay, so...
The reason why I was like, oh, when they killed off Moriarty, the show got worse.
Is because...
The reasoning they explained...
Because, you know, Sherlock fakes his death so many times.
And like, he fakes his death in the original book by...
Spoiler alert, from a book that was written in the 1800s.
Sherlock...
Fakes his death.
And like, he comes back.
But like, in the original books...
The author actually wanted him to be dead.
So he like, tried to kill him off.
Because he was done with Sherlock.
He was like, I want to write other things.
And then...
And then like, his fans back then...
Like, you know, just like today...
Fandom culture is always the same.
Send him death threats.
And...
You know, the usual.
Just...
You know, just the usual fan behavior.
Like they normally do.
They...
Send him...
Send Arthur...
What's his name?
Arthur Cullen...
Doyle?
Send him death threats.
It was like, bring back Sherlock.
He can't just be dead.
Ah, yes.
The tradition.
Some things are as true as time.
Nothing ever...
Nothing ever changes.
Anyway...
So...
So, and then...
Because, you know...
The author was like, you know, tired of...
Fearing for his life.
Which is normal to feel like.
Especially in the 1800s.
Because, you know...
Murder was so easy to get away with.
Back then...
You know...
Back then, murder was very easy to get away with.
So, you know...
The author...
Fearing for his life.
Was like...
Teehee, JK.
Sherlock's actually alive.
He faked his death, guys.
So, yeah.
So, he's like...
He actually faked his death.
He's not dead, guys.
The greatest detective...
Died that easily.
Just kidding.
So, yes.
Anyway, so, you know...
There's so many adaptations...
Of where...
You know, Sherlock has to fake his death.
And so...
When the...
Modern day adaption...
Adaptation...
Of Sherlock...
With like, you know...
Bendy Legs Cabbage Patch.
And his duo, Martin Freeman.
Their...
Solution...
To faking his death...
And how it was done.
And the thing is...
In season 2...
There were...
Before season 3 came out...
There were so many...
Fan theories...
Of how...
Bumblebee...
Chroma...
Bumblebee come...
Dungeon.
Oh, yeah.
There is a...
Bendy...
Oh, my God.
What is his actual name anymore?
Oh, Cumberbatch.
Okay.
Bendy Cumberbatch...
Name Generator.
Does it still exist?
This was my...
Oh, my God.
It still exists.
This was my...
This was back in the Tumblr era.
They actually still have it.
Don't you know?
He's a respected actor.
Okay.
So, if there was a generator...
And then you could get like...
Syphilis Candlestick...
Or Bandicoot...
Carrotstick...
There's also...
Buckminster Cogglesworth...
Blubber...
Bubcalculus...
It still exists.
I can't believe it still exists.
Oh, anyway.
Anyway.
So...
They're like...
There were so many theories...
On like...
How did Sherlock...
You know...
Fake his death...
In the modern era.
And...
And there were a lot of like...
Very creative theories.
And then...
What actually happens...
In this show...
Is that...
John...
Watson...
Just gets...
Drugged.
They like...
Give him some like...
Hallucigen.
So like...
The whole thing is that...
Sherlock always jumps off somewhere.
So like...
I don't care.
It's...
Season 3 was fucking terrible.
I'm gonna spoil it.
I didn't even watch season 3.
I...
I heard how bad it was.
That I didn't even watch season 3.
Because I was like...
That's so fucking dumb.
So...
John Watson...
Watches Sherlock jump off a building.
And he's like...
Oh my god!
But like...
What actually happens...
Is that...
Somebody...
Like...
He bumps into someone...
And they just...
Drugged him up...
And gave him some like...
And gave him like...
Hallucigens.
So it's...
He thinks...
He saw Sherlock...
Jumps off a building.
And then he...
And then Sherlock...
And it was like...
A stunt double or whatever.
And like...
Sherlock just walks away.
Like...
It's just like...
Alright.
And I was like...
What?
I think...
I think that was it, right?
Wait, I remember that.
I think...
It's been a while.
Is that...
Was that exactly how it went?
Because I watched that scene...
Someone...
Like they posted that scene...
There and then...
Yeah.
Like someone was like...
It was just one...
One short answer.
Just a little...
Yeah.
So...
Um...
Yeah, so...
That was basically how they explained...
How Sherlock...
Faked his death.
And I was like...
That's so fucking...
I was just like...
That's so dumb.
That's so fucking dumb.
But to be fair...
The writers for that show...
Don't know how to write past season 2.
Like...
Because...
For those who don't know...
The writers of the Sherlock show...
Um...
It is...
Uh...
Written by...
Mark Gatiss...
And Steven...
Uh...
What's his name?
Steven Moffat?
Moffat or something?
And...
Uh...
They don't know how to write past...
They don't know how to write past a certain season...
And it definitely shows.
Yeah.
Everything...
Like it just all fell apart after season 2.
After Moriarty was gone.
I mean, he was like the best part.
Honestly, Moriarty was honestly the best.
Moriarty...
Like...
The chemistry between Moriarty and like...
Uh...
Um...
Alright.
Generator time.
And it...
Between Moriarty and...
Billard Ball Cankersore...
Was like...
Really, really good.
And like...
Because, you know, the...
The rivalry between them was really interesting.
And like...
It's understandable that they had to kill him off because...
It does happen in the actual book.
But...
The way they...
They faked Sherlock's death was just too much.
Like, it was actually...
It was so fucking dumb.
Like, let's just drug up...
Let's just drug up...
John Watson.
And then be like...
He's okay.
He's dead.
That's how he...
John, he's dead.
Let me put you on hallucinogens real quick.
But he's fucking dead.
Alright, where was I?
Hanta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My pipelines of YouTubers was different.
It was N64, PC, Yu-Gi-Oh, everyone around me dying.
YouTubers, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Medi, thank you for the super chat.
Surprisingly,
no.
My...
My origin story was...
I told you guys before, but...
My...
Origin story...
Was...
L and Light.
I think that is, like, the origin story for a lot of fujo.
You see, L and Light were, like, my first...
They were...
Sorry, not L and Light.
They weren't my first, but, like...
They weren't my first fixation.
But Death Note was the very first anime that I've actually watched.
And that I was incredibly obsessed with.
Like, I was one of those fans.
I was incredibly obsessed with Death Note.
And I had, like, every single...
I had, like, all the collectibles and stuff.
And also, like, I kept up to date with, like, everything the author has done after Death Note.
Except for the ones about angels.
Like, I'm sorry.
If you respect your fans, you would understand that no fan can read through that one.
If you respect your fans, like, you don't want your fan to go through that.
Like...
Okay, so...
I didn't fully read Planet Men, but I did read the finale.
And...
How they... Okay, so, the whole thing is about all these angels trying to, like...
Trying to, like, kill each other.
What was it?
Oh my gosh, I don't even remember.
It ends really... It's a really stupid end.
Basically, the whole world just dies.
Like, it just disappears because the...
What was it?
Okay, one day...
Pondering...
I don't even remember.
Oh yeah!
There was a contest to become God.
So all the angels were killing each other...
To basically be the next God.
Anyway, so...
It ended with the God...
The God that won the contest...
Decided that... To end the world.
End the entire universe and existence.
Because he was like, humans don't deserve this.
Like, and then he's like... And then he kills himself.
And by killing himself, he ends the entire existence of the world.
Like, universe.
And that's how it ends.
So I was just like, wait...
That's stupid.
That's...
Like, it was so pretentious.
Okay, so...
You know how like...
Death Note, you can say Death Note was like...
Incredibly pretentious.
You can see... Not incredibly pretentious, but...
You can see it in some of the writing in Death Note that does get a little pretentious.
But it never like, breaks that mold...
Of like, you know, maybe it's trying to be too smart for its own good.
But Platinum End was actually like...
They tried to introduce so many of these like, really...
Elaborate concepts and like, philosophy and everything.
But it was so...
Yeah, like, Death Note is like, pretentious fun.
This one is like, they try to make you feel stupid.
But...
It doesn't make sense.
Like, what they're trying to explain...
Just doesn't make any sense.
They're like, making shit up as they go along.
So...
It was like...
Like, they're trying to like, question the meaning of life and all that shit.
And like, what it means to exist and everything.
And then I'm like...
It wasn't that much...
They tried to make the writing smart.
But like...
They were just confusing the readers.
And it was too...
Like, it's not that deep.
Like...
It's...
Yeah, so...
Yeah,
that's basically...
That's how it ends.
And then...
It just feels like...
What was the point of reading this?
Which I didn't.
I read like, the first couple of chapters.
And then I was like...
And then I heard it ended.
So then, I read the ending.
And I was like...
Oh, okay.
That's how it ends?
Like...
Like, everybody else was super happy.
Like, it's so weird, too.
Because in the chapter at the end...
No, the thing is...
The author writes...
Like, Bakuman was so good.
I really like Bakuman.
And I really like their newest comedy manga.
Where they tackle comedy and stuff.
And how the straight man and the funny man...
Like, they did that.
And those two were really good and very educational, too.
And...
Oh my god.
Planetman was just...
I just...
I don't know, like...
Yeah, like...
Like, it was so weird.
Because...
In the last chapter...
Everybody...
All the other characters were happy.
And they were living life.
And, like, enjoying life.
And then the fucking god was like...
No, life sucks.
War.
Depressed people are depressed.
Batman.
Famine.
Poverty.
Society doesn't deserve this.
And then he just ends himself.
But then, like...
They put that on you on the last part.
While, like, in the beginning of the last chapter...
The beginning of the last chapter, everyone was just happy.
Like, everyone was like...
Yippee!
I have a family now.
After this whole, like...
Battle to the death with all these angels.
I have a family now.
I...
Look at all my friends.
Oh my god, remember this character?
She's having a great time.
Knowing how to live her life.
And then they were like...
And then they cut to the emo kid.
He's like, no!
Life is terrible.
Look at all these children dying from starvation and famine.
And I'm like, what?
I'm just like...
Like...
It was such a huge whiplash.
I was just like...
But yeah, no.
Don't read Planet of Men.
I highly...
Just read anything else by any of the other authors.
Like, just read anything else.
There's so many other things you can read.
Like the Shouha Shoten.
Shouha Shoten was not written by the Death Note writer.
It was written by someone else.
But it was drawn by the Death Note illustrator.
So, I do recommend Shouha Shoten and Bakuman if you like Death Note.
I don't know what else did they do.
I think that's like...
He's only written like...
What's Skip Yamada-kun?
I don't know that one.
Oh, this one's a one-shot.
So, I highly recommend those two.
I can't wait for them to do another spin-off of Death Note.
They always update us with one-shots and be like...
So, what's going on in the Death Note universe?
Every couple of years.
So, I hope they do another one.
Okay, what's crazy was that...
Yeah, so...
I'm not here to be political, but like...
I'm just saying that in one of the one-shots...
They actually gave the Death Note to Donald Trump.
I was just like...
Why is he here?
Why is he...
I'm not making this up.
You can literally...
I remember reading that...
The moment it dropped.
I remember reading it on day one.
I was like...
I was not expecting that.
Imagine being me.
Little me.
Being really excited...
About reading the newest one-shot.
I was just like...
What?
Why is he here?
But yes, anyway...
Coyote, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Neopets created another furry yet again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, they could've just drawn any American president.
Oh my god.
Papa Smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My mom's credit card funds your super chat, so...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dr. Cranberry.
Yes, but you're not 10, Papa Smurf.
You're okay.
Dr. Cranberry.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki telling you you're 95.
Oh yeah, I remember reading this.
I'm trying to remember which one I read and which one I haven't.
This is like my problem these days.
Sometimes I just don't remember.
Next scene.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Back in my day, children just lied about their age...
Instead of complaining about being minors everywhere.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
This might be like...
Oh, what's the word called?
Where like...
Your thought might not be like agreed by...
By the majority.
Oh, what's that word called?
My hot take.
Yeah, this might be my hot take.
But like...
When minors complain about how like...
An 18 plus space does not cater to them.
And they complain about it.
And I'm just like...
Why?
Why are you here?
And like...
How a lot of minors nowadays...
Are like...
Everything has to be catered towards people who are underage.
And I'm like...
No.
That's what adult spaces are for.
Like...
A lot of them are now incredibly entitled.
So like...
What am I...
Okay.
This might get a little like controversial.
But like...
So there's like Friday Night Funkin'.
I saw like the quote drama behind it.
So...
Friday Night Funkin' just released their newest update.
Their newest Pico update.
And...
For those who don't know what Pico is...
Pico...
Back then, during Newgrounds era...
During...
Newgrounds era...
Was based off...
School shooting.
So...
But like...
Back then, in Newgrounds era...
It was like...
It was all about being edgy.
So that's who Pico is.
Like...
We all know where Pico's origin story is.
And Friday Night Funkin' is not...
Like...
Does not like hide that.
And...
But Newgrounds...
Was like...
Super edgy.
So no.
They got mad because...
Yeah, they talked about...
Cause like...
You know, they were talking about the Pico origin.
So a lot of like...
Minors got really mad...
About...
Like some...
The stuff in the newest Pico update.
But...
Some of the more edgier things...
They were saying...
Was apparently...
In a censored version.
Like in the non-censored version of the game.
So you don't see that...
If you turn...
If you don't see the stuff they say...
If you turn on the censors.
Like...
Cause I was like...
Oh yeah, that's like...
These dialogues are pretty edgy.
I was like reading it...
And like listening to the dialogue...
And I was like...
Oh yeah, some of these dialogues...
Are incredibly edgy.
But like...
If you know the characters...
It was based off of...
In Newgrounds.
Cause I grew up in Newgrounds.
Oh, I forgot to add Newgrounds by the way.
Um...
Deviantart...
Newgrounds...
Tumblr...
I forgot.
There was...
I was also in Newgrounds.
So I was like...
I watched a lot of like...
The Newgrounds animations and stuff like that.
So...
Um...
I was also like an edgy kid too.
So...
So like...
Uh...
They were complaining about some of the dialogue...
That was in the uncensored version.
Uh...
Hahaha.
In the uncensored version of the Pico update.
And then I was like...
Oh yeah, I know.
I can get why people are like...
Woah.
But then...
In New...
Back then in Newgrounds...
That was the thing.
Like...
Like the...
They were trying to...
Those were the characters back then.
And...
Like...
Tankman...
What...
Said all that shit.
Like...
Back in the...
I watched the tank...
I remember watching the Tankman animations.
And I was like...
That's literally what he says in the animations.
Like...
You can't...
They can't...
They didn't want to...
They can't just rewrite them.
Like...
Hahaha.
It is a product of it's time.
But you have to remember...
Tankman said all of that shit back then.
Hahaha.
He said...
A lot of fucked up shit...
In those animations.
Hahaha.
And they did put it...
In the uncensored version.
Hahaha.
Um...
It was a different time.
But like...
I saw like a lot of minors...
Were not happy about it.
And I was just like...
Isn't Friday Night Funkin'...
Like...
You know...
The title is basically like...
Friday Night Fucking.
Like...
That's...
Yeah.
It's just like...
I think...
Originally...
It was not for kids.
I'm pretty sure the creators originally created it...
Not geared towards children.
It just...
Um...
It just led...
Led to it.
Hahaha.
That's like...
Yeah.
The kid's all about...
Being subtle.
Hahaha.
Uh... Yeah.
And you literally...
Literally...
The death scene is...
Getting blue balled.
You literally get blue balled.
I don't know how...
They couldn't comprehend that.
Apparently...
If you do a hundred...
They added a new thing...
Where if you get...
A hundred percent...
Um...
At a level...
He throws girlfriend into the bed...
And they start getting freaky.
Hahaha.
They start...
They start Sims woohooing.
Um...
If you get a hundred percent...
It literally plays...
The Sims woohoo animation.
Hahaha.
Um...
So yeah.
No, that's...
That's why I'm like...
Kids like...
Like, I don't know.
I just feel like...
You don't need to understand the space you're in.
Cause like...
When things are made for adults...
They cannot be...
You know...
Like, you have to...
Be aware...
That like...
Uh...
The space was originally not made for you.
And like...
They...
They can't fully cater to you.
And complaining won't solve anything.
Hahaha.
Uh...
Let's see.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You're legally obligated to play Hollow Knight before Silksong releases.
Yeah, I actually really want...
Um...
If...
When I find out when Silksong releases...
I'll schedule a Hollow Knight playthrough.
Cause I do want to try to check out Silksong too.
But...
Um...
I want to...
Like I said, I want to be able to complete Hollow Knight before I do.
Uh...
I want to do Silksong on launch day.
Um...
Like the hun...
Thousands of other streamers are gonna do that too.
Uh...
MrBrokenBlood, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Moo, call me a cow and milk away.
Anything for Silksong.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
Play...
Finish the story mode.
There's no way I can do 100% on Hollow Knight.
I heard it's like a really...
Really long game.
But...
Um...
Just do the...
Finishing the story mode and stuff.
Um...
Oh yeah!
I know it's a little bit too...
I know it's early to say, but...
Uh...
Next week...
Um...
I think you guys might have noticed.
I'm like slowly getting through some of the charity goals and stuff from last year.
Um...
Now that my schedule is a lot more free.
And I'm less stressed out about everything else.
I'm still stressed out about taxes now.
But...
Cause now I realize I have to pay...
Actually pay more than what I just paid.
Uh...
There are more taxes that I haven't paid yet.
Cause I thought I did.
And I was like...
Yeah!
I finished it!
And I finished it, but like...
I don't have to worry about paying more.
But apparently I still have to pay more.
So I'm a little bit...
I'm like incredibly stressed out.
Anyway!
Next week...
Um...
I will be doing Visage next week.
And I'll be drinking for Visage next week.
And...
I dragged Mint along to be in call with me while playing it.
So...
I believe that...
Would be on Friday next week?
I don't remember what time I...
I was the one that set it up.
So...
Oh!
It'll be on Friday.
Next week.
So yeah!
Also like...
Starting soon...
I think you guys might notice...
I haven't been like...
Connect...
Networking very often.
Um...
I'm doing a lot of like...
Fleshy...
Uh...
Fleshy collabs.
It's because like...
Um...
With VTubers...
99% of the time...
I have to set up collabs for the VTuber collabs.
And I've been so busy.
And like...
I've been so busy...
Um...
You know...
Although I play some other things personally...
That...
I haven't really had time to set up these collabs.
I think the...
Bao and Stuffy collabs...
Been a collabs...
Like other than like...
I guess Sloppy Sisters too.
Um...
I set up the Sloppy Sisters collabs as well.
Like every time I have...
Um...
Like you know...
All the games I've suggested...
For Sloppy Sisters collabs.
Uh...
I set them up.
And um...
So like...
Uh...
99% of the collabs I set up with other VTubers...
I'm the one that...
Like...
99% of the collabs I do with VTubers...
I normally...
I'm the one...
That do the invites...
And set them up and stuff.
Um...
But like...
A lot of the fleshy ones that I join...
I get invited to them.
And...
So like...
You know...
I don't have to organize anything.
I don't have to...
You know...
Hit people up.
They're the ones that invite me...
To join them in their collabs.
So that's why I've been doing a lot of those.
Because they just send me an invite...
And I'm like...
Yeah, okay, yeah.
No problem.
I can join it.
Like...
Stuff like that.
Um...
But like...
VTuber ones...
Normally...
I have to organize them myself.
Uh...
And invite people.
Um...
So...
Uh...
That's why I never...
I haven't had the time to do...
That...
For a while.
Uh...
So...
Starting...
Like...
Now I'm...
Going back into it.
And...
Soon...
I want to...
Not soon...
But like...
Um...
I do want to get into like...
Meeting new people again.
Um...
Like I said, I've been incredibly busy.
So...
It's really hard to...
You know, reach out to people...
When I'm so busy all the time.
Trying to fucking fix my life.
But I'm gonna...
I'll try to reach out to new people.
Um...
Not soon, soon...
But like...
Maybe in like a couple...
Maybe in like two to three weeks.
Um...
But yeah.
Uh...
For like collabs again.
Um...
Also...
I realized that...
It's drawing near...
To...
The...
Anniversary of WrestleTuber.
And...
I have not planned anything for that yet.
Because I've been busy trying to...
Uh...
Fix stuff.
And with other work stuff.
So most likely...
WrestleTuber might be delayed...
Until I...
Figure it out.
Until...
Not figure out.
Until I...
Um...
Get less busy...
On the...
Business end.
And behind the scenes.
Um...
I just realized.
I realized that...
Like...
This week.
I was like...
Oh shit.
And I had zero plans for it.
I've done zero planning for it.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
So I think...
I think it was this month.
It's supposed to be this month.
Right?
It was either supposed to be this month...
Or next month.
I forgot already.
Um...
I'm not very good with dates.
But...
Whatever date.
If it was supposed to be this month...
Or next month.
It definitely...
Is gonna be delayed.
Because I've done zero planning for it.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
It was on...
It was in May?
Yeah.
Most likely, it will be...
It will not...
It will be delayed.
Most likely.
Um...
I just wanted to let you guys know.
That if everybody was like...
Oh, I can't wait for rest of October.
It's happening soon.
I just want to say that now.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Um...
Uh...
Skelem, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Here's 1 eighth of a Switch game.
Don't want to see Nintendo have to milk you too badly.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Gabbit, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
With $90, you can buy all three plushies.
Oh my God!
You're so right!
Guys!
Did you guys know?
That there's two days left of the YouTube plushie?
Oh my God!
Yes!
Everybody!
There's two days left!
I know it says 72 hours.
But I can't be bothered to download a new image that shows the countdown right now.
But yes!
There's still...
Less than...
48 hours!
To get your very own YouTube plushie of Croaky, TomatoMe, and OldGirlDoki!
Woo!
The moment the sale is over, these are gone forever!
So get them before it's gone forever!
Yippee!
You know what?
I'll just put this here for now.
But yeah!
Thank you for helping me sell!
Buy my merch!
Let's see...
Where else was I on?
I'll do like three more super chats and then I'm gonna call it here.
I'm done!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Mods, put a speedrun timer on the screen!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Next scene!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I played this game when I was like six or seven and thought it was too easy for reference to how for kids this game is.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I don't remember...
If I saw it...
I think like...
I just really enjoyed like...
You know how like...
You know as a child?
And that's how like people get you with YouTube Kids?
That's how the Spider-Man Elsa people got away with it for so long?
Like children don't really care?
But like...
Like okay, they care, but like also...
It's very easy to like...
Just grab a child's attention.
And then it's just like...
It's like...
They just put flashy things on the screen and then...
They're satisfied.
And that was me as a child.
I like replayed these Humongous games so many times because I was just like...
And then I would click that so many times because I was just so easily amused.
I was like...
And the thing is...
I replayed it so many times.
I know how the story ends.
I know how the story goes.
I know how the puzzles are like.
But I still played it like...
Replayed it so much because I just enjoyed it.
I just enjoyed it.
Like I was just brain rotted again.
I was the...
Prototype iPad kid.
I was like...
Let's go again!
Yippee!
I just...
I was very easily amused as a child.
Like the fact that I played the...
I remember playing the Blue's Clue's Treasure Hunt so many times.
But like...
It's the same story.
It's the same ending.
It's the same puzzles.
But I was like...
Blue's got two.
We got two!
And then he's like...
Let's go to the faking chair.
It was...
It was just...
Yeah.
I was farming my dopamine.
Because I did...
As a child, you know.
I haven't discovered competitive gaming yet.
And this is how I farm my dopamine.
Oh yeah.
Speaking of competitive gaming.
God, I wish I recorded a game.
But...
For those who didn't watch my Marvel Rivals stream.
I found out...
So I three stacked with...
I met a new person.
And like...
I've heard about this guy before.
Like in the...
Like...
Ranked scene.
Not competitive in the ranked scene.
Because he's like everywhere.
And like...
There was this guy named Sakura.
Who joined Pizza and I.
Pizza and I...
Into a three stack.
Because I thought it was so funny.
Watching those two argue with each other.
And they were both...
Consented to like...
Being put together in a three stack.
To continue arguing for us.
For our...
Fucking entertainment, I guess.
Like...
We live in a society.
And I found out...
That Sakura...
What is...
Is...
A professional rage baiter.
So...
I played...
Three games...
Off stream.
Because like...
Sakura was like...
I saw what his ELO was.
I literally straight up told him.
I wanna see if I can take you to Celestial.
And...
I wasn't throwing.
I just knew...
That like...
The games were not gonna be ideal.
So...
Um...
My...
Final...
Literally every game...
Was just...
Him...
And...
Three other people...
Just yelling and screaming at each other.
Throughout the game.
And...
I wish I recorded...
The last game.
Because the last game...
Like...
They were like...
Avoid me.
No, avoid me.
I...
I don't wanna waste my voice line on you.
And then...
Sakura was like...
No, you avoid...
I...
You avoid me.
And I'm gonna fucking farm your ass.
I'm better than you.
I...
I know everybody.
Pro players...
Think I'm the GOAT.
Think I'm...
That's why they play with me.
And I'm just like...
Meanwhile...
Me and the other support...
The two people...
That aren't saying anything...
Are getting...
Hard died...
By...
Spider-Man...
Venom...
Panther...
All three of...
Two of...
Me and my other support...
Are getting...
Hard died...
By Spider-Man...
Venom...
And Panther...
And nobody was helping us.
Well...
Four of my teammates...
Were just...
Non-stop...
Yelling at each other...
The entire time.
And...
And they were like...
They were like...
What the...
I don't remember the fucking play...
It was like...
Oh my god...
I remember...
Okay...
So, one of the quotes I remembered...
Was like...
You're the only one on your team...
None of us are on our mains right now...
And then...
Sakura...
Was like...
You don't know that...
I could be on my main...
On my alt account right now...
And then...
One of the other guys...
Was like...
You're level 61!
You have...
OW in your name...
Nobody who has an alt account...
Would name them...
With an OW...
I mean...
And then...
It was very hard to concentrate...
It was incredibly hard to concentrate...
Guys...
And then...
And then the Bucky player...
Was like...
I'm not even taking this seriously...
And I'm carrying your fucking fat ass...
Right now...
And I'm still doing everything...
What the fuck are you doing?
I'm on a fucking alt account...
And I'm still doing better than you...
It was...
Oh my god...
Like...
I legitimately couldn't think...
At all...
Like...
It was just non-stop screaming...
I wish I recorded it...
It was so...
It was actually...
A wild ride...
Yeah...
So...
Oh my god...
But...
What I realized is that...
I realized then...
That like...
Like...
The existence of professional rage baiters...
Like their entire...
Existence in that game...
Was to just...
Make people angry...
Like...
He would say...
Just random shit...
That he knows...
Would piss someone off...
On our own team...
On my own fucking team...
Like...
We were not winning any...
We were...
I knew it was like...
Actual...
GGs...
On character select...
Oh my god...
Um...
But yeah...
Next time...
If like...
That ever happens again...
I'll give you guys a recording of...
Of it...
It was actually...
It...
No...
I...
I know like...
Me saying it...
Does not...
Does not reflect...
How fucking...
Crazy that game was...
Like...
I...
There was literally like...
No moment...
Where they didn't stop yelling...
Each other...
You know what I mean?
There was...
It was just...
Just...
I could not think...
Next time...
I will give you guys a recording...
It was absolutely crazy...
Like...
I was not...
I was just...
Watching the show...
As it unfolds...
The funniest part...
Is that we could have won...
If like...
The team was not screaming...
At each other...
But...
I'll give you guys...
I'll get a recording next time...
If I ever do it again...
Let's see...
I'll do one more super chat guys...
Alright...
HongGeorge!
Thank you for this...
Oh wait, actually no...
Sorry HongGeorge...
Actually, I'll do two...
I'll feel bad if I take away your right...
You know, it's like...
You win the gacha...
And then you get a gold pull...
And then the...
And then...
Like the server maintenance...
Hits you guys...
In the middle of it...
And then it's like...
Sorry...
We weren't able to keep your data...
From the server...
We weren't able to take your data...
We weren't able to save the data...
To the server...
In the middle of the server maintenance...
Anyway...
HongGeorge, thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
It got rolled back...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
God, I wish...
I wish...
I have to write my physical letter...
Today...
To fucking send...
To the...
My tax center...
And then wait...
15 days!
Yay!
Let's see...
Where was it?
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
Hi Doki...
My birthday was on April 1st...
But my super chat didn't get through...
I can still get a happy birthday?
Of course!
You can, of course!
Happy birthday to you...
Happy birthday dear Noire...
Yay!
Happy birthday...
Have a great birthday...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
Alright guys...
I'm gonna call it here everybody...
I hope you guys had a great time...
Hanging out with me today...
I haven't had lunch yet...
So I'm gonna grab some lunch...
And then...
I'm gonna go walk Doki Amber Doge...
So I'm gonna see you guys later...
I'll see you guys tomorrow everyone...
No Twitch stream tonight...
For those who weren't planning on camping...
I'm just gonna chill today...
As always everybody...
Stay hydrated...
Posture check...
Get up and move around...
To get that blood flowing...
And if you...
Stay up for me...
Head to bed, cause...
You deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody...
Bye guys!
Bye!
Oh, where's my ending screen?
There it is.
Bye!